i actually met him when i was like 11
around that time because he came i took
him to the never land range
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do the show
directly right my kid phelps
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez
oh my god omg omg hi
i went back and did stand-up this
weekend and uh
how'd it go it's [ __ ] hard i don't
remember being so hard
i swear to god it's like you know if you
don't work out in 435 days and then they
go
welcome to the la marathon pop the
[ __ ] by the third block
you know after the first three shows i
sat
first two shows or after the first
second night
i sat there and i went man this is
if i never think i loved it because you
know i i don't really show a lot of
respect
to it or talk about it that much but i
cared so much
that it made me realize i do love it
because like a woman if a woman had left
you you're trying to get her back
you would be having the same
conversation like what do i need to do
man i need to like
and it's the first time in my life i've
been doing it 42 years
that i remember lee travino told me one
time you know george i finally you know
i got older and i can't play as well
and this has never happened to me in my
life before and i would say
those like it's harder than i thought it
was and that i wasn't as prepared
as i should have been that's not going
to be on the podcast taking that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out
no okay no no no you got to put in there
so let's see let's see
you got it yeah let me show you let me
show you so
it's a really basic video it's just me
doing like
how george lopez would look if he was
looking for his car in the parking lot
that's all it is it's just like don't
say that that [ __ ] what that's
all it is that's not because it's like
every little thing like how george lopez
would look
like ordering he'd just be like you got
the number four
with medium frieser you know that's
basically all it is
so i did like three of those on
tick-tock and and then
but what was what was the big thing of
about
like what what launched one launched you
so i do i
i do stuff where i like impersonate
teachers little like teacher like
movements and then i do like news
reporter i have a character named junior
who's just like you know like the
where's my guy guy who's like where's my
hug yeah
you know that like that the frustration
so i i didn't do any
did you do any kachinas
now yeah i'll get away we're going to
stop and get you away against
potato lobster village so so um
so you would just move to
remember about dm dude i think mayan's
the one who told me about he goes hey
this guy's doing you like
yeah on tick tock and then what's your
name what's your ad
my name is leo gonzalez leo gonzalez not
leo
gonzalez no no you wanna know something
real quick when i was uh when i was
because i was obsessed with george when
i was little not no more
uh when when i was when i was a little
kid i used to look at my name
it's just leo gonzalez and i was like lg
gl
backwards 11 letters in both names right
now when i was 10 or 11 i was like that
was my like
i like laid it out i'm like look one day
we're going to meet like look
elliot g lindsay george like foreign
yeah i always thought about that and
then i i actually met him when i was
like
11 around that time because he came i
took him to the never land range
too much for me i'm going to my room
which one the real one or the one behind
the [ __ ] clothes
the uh yeah yeah so and you know
the thing with see you're not he's not a
standard comedian so
stand-up comedians don't i don't know
that never give me any
really respect you i mean you have to
earn it no
but they never say but you see a guy
that was 11 saw my show
and then all of a sudden you know he's
like hey you know i i like them i was
influenced by them
it's it means more here because this guy
was were you in fresno
and i was in hanford and yeah oh i love
hamper and he's not a no
he's not a comedian i do i work in the
theater in hampton
no and the thing is like i couldn't
afford the show because i
wouldn't have a place to live and and so
when you were in hanford
we had only i had only heard like
somebody was like george hope is this
staying at this hotel
and i was like in eighth grade so i got
on my scooter with one of my one of my
homegirls and we went over there
and true story like furrow like he
he there was like two limos there i was
like two flex
but there was two limos there and he got
in one of them
like in the back and he drove like they
drove off
and then not even joking it was like
four of us kids there
the limo leaves like two blocks we see
it and it turns around and it comes
right back
and george came outside and he was like
all right like how are you doing i was
like
bro and i was like nah it was crazy i
went back you went back yeah
i took the picture i'll show you the
picture right now too well you guys talk
a little bit those were the years i was
[ __ ] put the most no i was always
kind of kind of
it was crazy it was crazy you know
i think you know i mean when you're a
professional
you have a lot of different
personalities i don't know if if anybody
ever
has one true person i think back in the
day they did
like the old man they go [ __ ] that old
man's [ __ ] meaning that was his
personality but i think now with
everything and the way things are
you're different to some people you're
different other people and i think
that's the problem people try to be
one person look at that photo this is uh
look at it so i was a little lighter at
that point
you could see that ferris wheel in the
background raise your hand jordan
yeah where's my hand can we get
[Laughter]
yeah that's around what six two thousand
five yeah two thousand and i was like
seven or eight yeah yeah yeah it was
like right before high school for me
it was crazy did people give you [ __ ]
because you liked me in school no no and
that's the thing
they're like kiss i like kissing they
call me a kiss freak you know you know i
was a big kiss fan and
well not because it was you it was
because like all my friends were all
like little cheerleaders and so
it was all so and it was funny stuff
like it wasn't
that was the stuff that nobody ever
heard like why are you crying right tv
show
so it was like every day like at school
like my that was how i kind of like
built myself in eighth grade because
everybody just nicknamed me george lopez
and so you know one uh one thing that i
was like you know what let me not tell
you i don't even want to tell you
because you're
it's you and i'm with the officer of the
law
but when i was in eighth grade in my
little trillo friend i still got a sweat
down there was
there was a a big george lopez poster
because you uh when you
the you aired on like the one of the
local channels
and it had like the cast right there so
my friends i wasn't with them
to for like as a birthday gift in
october they
grabbed it they cut out your face and
they gave it to me as a gift
oh and so that was illegal but
they gave it to me as a gift and i took
that for like halloween i wore and it
was like the best thing ever but like
yeah good [ __ ] a halloween costume now
yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go no
that's the influence you had you know
i'll i'll tell you back when you're
starting
you're saying why are you crying why are
you crying and everything you said uh to
me
i wasn't a little kid that was all real
yeah that's that's the way
i was brought up you even had my swagnos
you know and right they loved your and
and the stories you tell you know hey
don't forget bring me a plate
you're going to the wedding nah that's
sushi she's getting married and white
yeah and but yet bring me a plate
you know she would it was it was so
funny
you know to me it was real i know man
and that's like you know i think when
you
let's say if you build if i'm thinking
about it right the analogy would be like
if you if you built a
if you built a company but you started
in the garage
like bezos you know they have that thing
where he's sitting there and he was sold
old books and it says
amazon is in the garage so you think
about those those days and you think
about
it was just my grandmother my grandma
would say you know are you here who's
getting married
who uh yeah again
i go to the wedding i went to the first
two treats [ __ ]
six [ __ ] kids she should wear a white
dress with a [ __ ] black sleeve
and a [ __ ] hole in the middle like my
grandmother went
zero to sixty and i would just be like
that's it and you know
in and look you know it's funny man
because i think about a little bit of
what happened this last weekend at that
club
was a loss of direction and then
when i was in new york and i was really
[ __ ] miserable with my stand-up and
then
this guy came to see me and he said hey
man can i give you some constructive
criticism and i said yeah of course and
he's like you know when i see you i
don't know what you like i don't know
what you don't like
i don't know what your family's about i
don't know where you're from i don't
know your politics
he said man you need to get [ __ ] that
people can relate to you because it's
sort of
mundane kind of stuff and then he goes
who and your family is like funny and
then that night i walked back from new
york to caroline's to the hotel and i
said
[ __ ] that's god it's about to be my
grandmother so over the next day during
the day i stayed in there
and i wrote [ __ ] and when i went out it
changed the direction of my
the life of my family my career that one
thing
that said like who is it you know it was
and it was my grandmother disneyland
you already went you remember when you
scratched your back on the fence when i
pulled you under i kind of stripped that
we're sneaking in everywhere well i'm
glad you're here now this would be a
good with that got a good
cause thing right here huh this is good
this is like one of those commercials
for uh uh when
forest lawn the three generations of
latinos there it is
so here's what's happened since
gil has been on oh my god hi so
he wasn't on social media at all right
that's right
facebook page and what did you use it
for like you're looking at pictures of
kids and yeah just like
just friends kids yeah you just no
update friends hey this is what's going
on i wouldn't even add
friends of my kids because at that time
i was
i was a working cop i i i didn't want to
i don't know what you're doing but it
could be it could be
i mean we use it for entertainment but
it
what what is facebook like when you're
not when you're not trying to
you're just trying to stay in touch with
your family what's that like you look at
it every day well
yeah i do i look at it every day and
it's just staying in touch with family
and friends see what
people are doing you know you all of a
sudden somebody pops up that
you haven't seen in years and there you
go you you talk to them
it's just totally friends and that's all
it was to me
until this thing broke and then it just
got
wilder than my wildest expectations you
know when somebody would
if somebody was a comedian and they did
like the tonight show and
you know like drew carey like he got
called over to the couch by johnny
carson and then the next day you're a
big star
what it is now with with all of the
streaming services
and all of the you know channels and
shows like there's thousands of [ __ ]
things to watch
but when those thousand things to watch
become what was it called the
night was it was the official title
night stalker search for a serial killer
i think or hunt for zero
so netflix amongst all the other ones
but netflix is still the place that
people go to
uh and somehow they know your chicano
that you're alone like are you still
watching yeah
i'll get crying so when that comes out
it's it's [ __ ] trending all over the
world
and here you are and there you are and
now people see you
and now what was small the circle is now
like you said you'd be
getting messages from everybody all over
the place yeah and
what's it let me ask that what's what's
it been like since
what do you what's it been like for you
personally not like just
time consuming a lot of time consuming
because i wake up in the morning i wake
up early
and i look at my ipad
i take it with me everywhere i open up
my ipad and there's
all kinds of messages you got to read
you got to respond
and and i've told my i have to do this
because i don't want people to think
that i'm better than anybody you know
i'm not an actor so you answer all the
people that
i answered everybody unless there's
something on there specifically
you know like i i even answered one guy
that admittedly says hey i'm a crook
he says i'm like a robin hood he says i
steal from the rich but i give it
all back to the poor that's what i'm
doing you know i take money from rich
guys
and i said well thanks i hope our pads
don't cross he says hey don't worry
like white collar or no no he wasn't a
white caller and he just said
uh i just want to say the criminal yeah
he says i'm a criminal
you're not you caught criminals but
that's the best documentary i've ever
seen and my hat's off to you you're good
one of these days i hope i get a chance
to meet you i said well i hope i don't
become one of your victims
he says no way i just take money over
here to give to the poor
but that's all i do and you believe that
[ __ ] i don't know
i never never talked to the guy i don't
trust anybody do people give money
to the poor anymore like would a guy rob
and
those are his words he ain't coming out
here hey no well
he didn't tell you where he was from
though yeah he did but a matter of fact
he just said hey i'm gonna be he's not
from he's not even from the united
states
i remember that i don't know what
country he's from and he told me
uh he sent me a message and said i'm
going to be going out uh
who's more notorious they have those do
the that's some pretty
pretty wild guys in england you know
jack the ripper where the jaguar from
there jack the ripper you know they
richard wrote on a wall jack the knife i
had to ask richard i said hey what does
jack the knife mean
he said that's just another name for
jack ripper
he told me whether that from mcdonald's
did i do was playing the piano no that's
mack than
mac tonight
remember they had a dude that was
playing the piano like jack of the box
had the clown that
has a family and then mcdonald's trying
to do
where the where the hamburger i don't
know
no that i don't remember i thought
better about the music the song
nah so so anybody
mac the knife no back tonight
uh um and how are you enjoying that dude
is it is it fun how's your wife enjoying
it it's enjoyable for me
more enjoyable for me because i get to
see for the first time in my career
uh first time in life i i've always my
wife has been the wind beneath my wings
right
she always allows me to walk in front
you get the attention you do this
because of this documentary people are
asking her for autographs they're
recognizing her
and people are going up and saying thank
you you stole the whole show you know
the whole documentary and so she's
getting accolades that she so justly
deserves well you know i mean it
affected your whole family like you know
your family moved out and you were there
and everybody wasn't safe and your
friends even you know in the law
enforcement
and um so with
with with regard to that [ __ ] yeah man
because like sometimes criminals go
after you know
sure criminals go after them he he said
he was buying my house we found some
shoe prints now it wasn't via via shoe
prints as it turns out it probably was
the stadia
because we hadn't seen the stadia yet
which were concentric circles
little dots all over the bottom of the
shoe right but a week before he was
arrested right after
a mission vehicle we found some uh
shoe prints around my house that
shouldn't have been there and
so then we got some we got some people
watching my house that [ __ ]
is crazy family wasn't there anymore
but i was still there and so we had
people watching uh
my house we we got some coverage for it
so it was all good uh my kids are loving
it because
they're getting my kids at that time
were 7
10 and 13 and they're getting so many
you know
and two of them are really into the
social media stuff and they're getting
messages from kids they haven't seen
that since elementary school you know
hey man we had no idea your dad did this
because we didn't talk about it
you know but i would say i would say
that for
culturally you know for somebody like
you
to be the the front and center person
that it means a lot it shouldn't just be
actors or or comedians or entertainers
it should be
people like people like you and probably
the best thing that has come out of this
for me
is to hear from people uh in our culture
i'd say
the poveressa you know the poor people
that
don't get attention anything and they're
just reaching out and saying thank you
we now have someone we could look up to
you represented us well
we're so proud thank you and
uh that touches me that does
are you sure it's not part of that beer
touching
so you already finished that one yeah
that's it
right here he wants to be like me around
your weight coming in that [ __ ] three
drinks
where's be real hey oh so
um what what did you think of uh of of
of be real like uh as a person and that
show because that show grant that show
did good huh
yeah i think our second best performing
one all right and then uh
so what did you think of him are you can
i ask you if you use
marijuana for anything no no okay you're
clean you just drink a book just drink a
lot
now yeah me too all right so so
tell me what you think because because
uh you have
you know and it's funny because i think
the thing that could that connected us
again was
that this weekend i took a gummy to
to sleep and it gave me anxiety before
the show
i'm not doing that [ __ ] anymore like i
didn't feel good
i didn't feel i felt i had anxiety
and i never had it and i think it was
because i used that
[ __ ] thing to go to sleep that it
wasn't out of my system i almost
cancelled the second show i'm like
guys what the [ __ ] you're talking about
the [ __ ] gummy god dammit
[ __ ] it i was like oh [ __ ] crazy
i had no idea number one
because of my age because i didn't
follow him because i didn't do my
homework before he came down here i
didn't know who be real was
then i heard he was a rap star he's a
rapper and
so we sat down here and what i've
written on my social media
right i thought he was very articulate
very intelligent knew his very
knowledgeable when it came to the flower
or is it
cannabis or as he says the flower flower
uh
and it was a real pleasure it was really
nice meeting him and
and he's nothing more than another guy
you know and
and he was very nice to me and i was
very excited my grandkids were so
excited
uh and and it was he was really
genuinely sincere and he had nice things
to say about the sheriff's department
he did yes and the way he versus lapd
you know i'm gonna tell you that you
know being from here
and dealing with the foothill division
that was the division that they would
call
and um you know the rodney king
stuff and all that stuff that i had no
i mean and it's not that we're criminals
but there was always cops around our
football games
sure around the school you know come and
break up parties
and one of the things that's
most shocking to me is that
the sheriffs were in that position in
the lapd like the sheriffs were
in more of a position of authority and
lapd was not
like i had no idea about that i don't
think anybody even really knows that
that the sheriffs were the ones to look
out for and the lapd was the ones that
you could [ __ ]
well yeah nice thing to say and i've
written nothing but
uh nice things about him i was so
excited
i i really was i got all excited because
uh
within the past week i got a message
that he's now following me
and i'm saying wow this is a guy you
know it's
kind of like you you know travels
performed
yup a little time and yet
he's also following me and he said he
was there if i ever need anything
you know if i needed so it was just it
was nice good dude yeah i'm glad because
you know
um as people get older i think that the
the cbd aspect of someone's you know
physical stuff
works you know mexicans oh all our
grandmothers used it
sure and in the old tequila bottle with
the leaves in there and then they would
rub the alcohol was like
that was number one for day one sure
you know and uh so i think that uh as we
get older
that that weed but listen that dude's
another type of
of marijuana dude that dude
smoke [ __ ] when i went to go do this
podcast
they smoked two [ __ ] joints i found
one in my car i smoked that much and i
was out of my mind
i can't do the two [ __ ] things like
that well i i've
seen some of his posts and every post
that i see is filled with smoke
i don't know how they [ __ ] do that i
don't know because i don't use if they
do it more power to them
as long as nobody's going out of there
and driving all jacked up
it's all cool i don't care what they do
it's a big business man
it's big business so so um who got you
on social media and how easy was it for
you to
to get on it was a good friend of mine
mike beltran who's a
referee and a good friend member of the
sheriff's department we've been friends
for years
what's your handle uh real gill
real real gill real gil carriel
real gil carrillo yes on everything
okay that means that it's not a good
name when he says on everything that
means like it's like
no is it like on instagram or twitter
instagram instagram are you on twitter
two or no no
no twitter one thing at a time i haven't
even real guild cardio 815.
you better not be following me you
better be following me because we'll
[ __ ] get down right now he is
yeah he's got some good are those all
your posts right there oh yeah
let's see if let's see if he has me in
there because
i started this kid out yeah i just made
a
responded to one that posted i tell you
they put out on your behalf with the
girl and the peace guys yeah
tell me what that oh he's you're from
there too right from fresno area
so so gil was tell me what you let's
talk about i i saw a post
just yesterday and it really touched my
heart uh
it's a latino family they're mexicans
out working the peace cause
and their daughter had just graduated
and she's out there with her family
in her capital yeah yeah yeah and it
touched me to show
she would show her mom and dad and
uh it meant everything to me yeah
all i wanted to do was make my dad proud
my mom i had six sisters my mom was
always proud of me i was
you know yeah she i could do no wrong or
right but my dad i wanted to make him
proud
now this girl this young tender age
with a world in front of her persevered
graduated was a high school college high
school
and yet she's out there uh
yeah her parents could be proud of her
and god bless her you know uh so you had
six sisters you don't have a brother
no no brothers and six sisters what was
your relationship
with like with your father my dad was he
a loving father
was my dad my dad loved me i loved him
but we didn't talk much you know it was
you know the day before he died i
i just had to go up and tell him i never
said i love you so i asked everybody to
clear the room
in the hospital and i said dad i grabbed
sand i said i got to tell you something
i've never
said this to you before he says what i
said i love you dad
and my dad holding on to my hand said me
too son man
and and so he didn't say i just want to
hear him say i love you
and i and i tried everything in my my
what is that within me
to be to make him proud of me so then i
told my sister one of my older sisters
at
and the next day after he passed away
the next morning
and the next day
my sister was and my mom were going
through his stuff and he had a little
steel box
and opened up that box and she says you
want to know you didn't hear your dad
say he love you how much he loved you
here is the deed of the house the
insurance papers
funeral arrangements 10 000 cash every
important document he had was in that
box
wrapped up in this newspaper article and
it's incredible
it's it's an article about me when i was
in vietnam
helping to start an orphanage over there
and i was asking for help from the
people of uh pig rivera
wow it's just that's how much he lived
how come he couldn't how come he
couldn't tell you
it was a different culture back then you
know right does your dad tell you that
he loves you
we said it maybe uh two months ago for
the first time on the phone
yeah what made him say it um i i
there was some stuff going on with my
mom and and i was like
i was struggling over here and he was
just like well
well what is it culturally man i don't
know i i thought he was going to say
because i was blasting them on social
media you know yeah yeah
yeah i'm actually i'm still waiting but
how come what what
what is that though i mean uh i guess
oscar de la hoya was chasing
still is still alive and they just
what is it in them it's and it's not
it's not like there's a
a million people that do and just a
handful that don't nobody does
you know i i will tell you uh when i was
transferring from
station to uh this headquarters gang
unit
they did an evaluation you get your
evaluation and i was evaluated
being an outstanding i had never
received an outstanding evaluation
so i went to my mom's house and i showed
it to her
and my dad was already sick with cancer
he had two or three of his brothers from
new mexico out here visiting him at the
time
and he's just sitting there and my mom
says mira
your son and he read it and he said
i'm proud of you son that's the first
time he'd ever said that
never in my life and she said she looked
at him and my mom you know
she was my protector she just jumped in
there she says you mean it took 29 years
of life and somebody else will say how
good your son was
before you could say you're proud of him
and he said no that's not it at all
he said not telling him that made him
want to work harder that was part of
becoming a man
true and i wanted him to work hard
he says he's accomplished that and i'm
sitting there internally i'm saying oh
goodwin
you're quick on your feet dad that's a
good reason that's right and
especially in front of your brothers
following year he's now gone
his boss his boss was the father of
supervisor mike kentonovich mickey was
his my dad's boss
best friends and mickey called my mom's
house and said hey
can you have gilbert come down and pick
up uh
everett's christmas gift every year gave
them the same thing
a turkey and a bottle of whiskey wow and
he gave it to all the employees and says
have him come pick it up
so i went down there and i went in this
little construction office and there's
three four guys sitting there one of
them looked up he says you must be
carillo's boy
i said yes sir and he says oh it's a
pleasure to meet you my name's leno i'm
i'm negro i'm blinky you know i said
i've never had the honor of meeting you
guys but
i heard you i heard your names my dad
and he's
and one of them says you know your dad
was so proud of you
from the time you went into the army
then you come out you started college
he says and then you became a cop over
that day he couldn't stop talking about
you
and but what is it in the in the what is
it in the
what do you think it is grant does your
dad tell you love your mom what but what
is it
because it's not it's not i love you and
then you have to talk for 10 more
minutes it's just saying
i love you and that's it and like i love
you okay and what else oh you know
the reason even that is it vulnerability
is it i think it's nobody told them it's
probably because they'll [ __ ] start
crying if they tell you
and they don't want to do that i don't
know my dad uh to this day i think is
the wisest man i've ever met
but he raised there were 11 10 10
siblings
in his family and his his father died at
an early age then his mom got married
again step dad came in
and tried to hit on somebody in the
family that he shouldn't have
and they run him out of dodge so my dad
became the father for the family at an
early age
he took care of all of them then he got
married to my mom
and he had seven kids he was out here in
l.a now
and he did everything kept everybody in
my family out of jail
and kept a roof over our house and fed
us
and my dad i never asked my dad for
something i really didn't need
or want the only thing i i i asked him
for that i really didn't need
was a saxophone i wanted to play sax
when i was a kid
and he made it happen but
i never lacked for anything you got you
how did he get you a sex
he rented it he rented rented a sack so
i could
start playing it and once he saw that i
was going to continue playing it things
were going good
he bought it and so i played for years
and it was uh that's a he did everything
he never
told me as a teenager you know because
at 17 i went into the army but before
then
he never told me to do anything he would
hint
or give me a question hey maybe you
ought to think about doing this
you know maybe i i knew i'd come home
and my nickname for my dad used to call
me bibi
and how can we call you bibi i have no
idea where they came from
i don't know if since i was a baby and
he said bibi you know
he called me bb so if he'd come home
tired because he was a
work for a construction company he was a
laborer he'd come home and he was tired
i said hello daddy
and he'd say hello bb well i knew i was
everything's good
if i said hello dad and he said
hello gilbert oh and i said holy [ __ ]
you know something's wrong something's
something's bothering him if i said
hello and he just said
hello but wouldn't even look at me or
he just ignored me i knew my [ __ ] was in
trouble
for something i didn't do or something
he was up he was upset at me for
so then you know i'd get out cut the
grass pull the weeds do whatever had to
be done
you know and you know when somebody
works at hard right you know my
grandfather dug ditches he worked
construction
and the days are short man and the
weekends are short so you look at it
he leaves in the morning comes [ __ ]
back all muddy and dirty
eats goes to sleep and on the weekends
they didn't really do anything and just
go back to work again and it's
there's no time for you know
sitting around and playing catch or
[ __ ]
it's almost like that's like that's me
telling you i love you like look what
i'm doing for you like look at like
we're here we're on
we're on this side and i'm doing all
this for you so yeah brothers and
sisters
i'm an only child and then on saturdays
my dad would get up my dad did all the
all the shopping so my dad would get up
on saturdays
he'd look at the papers and he did three
or four markets to go buy
and tomato sauce by the case everything
by the case had a little uh cabinet he
did all that
yeah my mom never drove
you know he'd go do that make sure
everything was there
and every saturday [ __ ] party packed
sodas
yeah party pack um starting to fight did
you go to spartan final that's where
everybody went
back then we couldn't brand costco or
whatever bell brand potato chips
and a case of quartz for him
and he'd sit there that's that would go
during the week for him [ __ ]
man that's heavy duty man yeah he was
hard work i never knew him to take a
vacation until after
uh after retired he retired when they
found cancer in his lungs
and he says okay now it's my turn did he
smoke yeah he did
lucky strike non-filter [ __ ] but he was
getting
even after his death he got it uh he
worked as a kid he worked in the mines
he was getting pension from the black
lung black lung disease from
from there and uh but he was a smoker he
didn't bother him
but those were so in the in the mines
but where do you where was that where do
you grow up
gamerco new mexico which is just outside
of gallup new mexico which is the
biggest town right there
and he was a hero in the little town i
heard stories
uh matter of fact i went into the bar
last time i was in gallup
a few years ago he uh there was a bar
called the tropics
and so i went in his brother took us in
there my wife and myself
this is where your dad used to work as a
kid and hung out
and he became a hero because he was 12
years old and he was a bar back you know
he just
hustled around in there and for tips
whatever they'd give him
there was a robber that came in he saw
the robber coming in saw the gun
so he grabbed the money out of the cash
register and then hid underneath the
counter
and close the door behind him so the
robber got what he got
he left and then he came out he said hey
i got the money here he became the local
hero
you know and and he was good so i'm down
there and i
went to the bar and the bartender looked
and he says uh excuse me he says you
guys aren't from around here very
obvious you know what do you uh
what brings you to this price i said my
dad used to work here as a kid yeah
he said who's your dad and i said
evaristo carrillo
he says we've owned this bar 50 years
your dad never worked here i said i
don't care how long you build it my dad
worked here
and he says well no
he says your dad didn't work here oh
he says my dad is on this and i'm saying
i don't care what you say
wow he says right there here's a picture
he took this picture off the bar
he says there's the owner of the bar
right there i said well i wouldn't
bit me in the ass i just saw my dad
worked here my wife got the picture she
went over to the pool table where there
was light
and she says hey he was in it isn't this
your dad
and i went up there and before i
committed
i called his brother i said hey you
recognize anybody in this picture he
goes hey there's my brother
wow my i called up my mom immediately
she was hey i found a picture of my dad
up on the wall of the tropics
how old was he had a teenager well then
at the time that he took this picture
now he wasn't working there now he's a
drinker
no and you know and you see these old
cowboy movies belly up to the bar
well the reason is they didn't have bar
stools in you just take
your bunsen go up to the bar they had a
bar rail there
right and so all these guys my mom
always said he was a dapper dresser and
you look at this picture
he's the best dressed guy there and
they're sitting there
so i said mom i found a picture of him
and she says was it winter was it summer
i said mom
let's take it inside the bar how do i
know she says is he wearing a felt hat
or a strawberry oh my god
i said sorry i said oh it was summer
then so how did your dad get that get
that with the clothes how did he get
i have no idea matter of fact they just
sent me a picture it had to be somebody
has to be somebody in the friend or
family or something
they just sent me a picture bill gates
over here
no but he had no social media at all he
had no
no social media so with this yeah you
following them
not yet so let's talk about let's talk
about tick-tock i want to kick-talk
being around
tick tock i want to find his picture it
started as something else
it was like musically yeah yeah i wasn't
on it at that time
and then the only reason i made it was
because it was like uh this is one
character that i was seeing on twitter
so i was like oh
i wanna make it on tik tok so i can see
those
and my dad's al capone over here on the
left
that's my dad listen man can can we
can you show that do you know that
there's a camera's up here
do you know that there's a lot of
pictures like this
that
yeah you know there's a lot of pictures
like that from
of of our culture that you see
and you usually see them in other other
families but
there's a whole hidden heritage let's
say a hidden heritage that we have
of all of that stuff i just got back
amazing oh yeah
[ __ ] amazing and and later on in life
now i'm working homicide i started
buying suits i went to a place in
montebello
and a little by the old garmar
theater just a little place i went there
buy me a suit
and the guy his name was eddie garcia he
says
you know your dad used to come and have
his suits made he may use
my daddy's my tailor-made sushi yeah
he said i want to make a tailor-made
suit for you i said maybe when i get
rich right now i'm just buying the [ __ ]
you got on the rack
you know that had to come from somewhere
man because
to get a suit made was a big it's a
[ __ ] big deal like
because it's because it's different than
than saying i need a suit
than someone who takes pride in in
clothing yeah like i'm gonna have my
suits made and my shirts made and
everything that
comes from some place he was a dapper
dude yeah so i came from some place
i don't know yeah you know i i can
remember
he was probably a happy guy he was
probably a partier when he was young
because
when i got out of the army my first week
at home i ran into some friends
and three of us on the block had all
come back from the service within two
weeks of each other
and he said you know what tonight we're
gonna sit on the block and we're getting
wasted
so i said all right let's go do it so we
went to the liquor store
bought a bunch of [ __ ] and we drank and
i got blasted
i made it home that night block away
made it home
my sister told me next morning hey how
do you feel i said i feel fine why
he says well you were all wasted last
night all right
she didn't remember i said remember what
well i fell asleep in the toilet my mom
was banging on the door
my dad finally came up there and said
gilbert open the door i said
i'll be right out you know and i came
out went to bed nothing was said my mom
comes home from work that next day
and my mom says hey cabron que paso and
i said mom you know hey what
i got drunk last night with my my
brothers out there
she says well you
you just wait till your dad gets home i
said what's dad gonna do he's gonna put
me over my
over his knee and spank me mom come on i
just got out of the army i've been to
vietnam i'm a man now mom
what's he gonna do to me so i wasn't
afraid my dad i saw my
dad driving up in his truck and my heart
started pounding
and so he came and i was just walked
straight into the bedroom and my mom
says
your dad wants you i walked in there and
i said
yes daddy says close the door and him
and my mom and myself are in the room
and he says
what happened last night that is very
simple tommy veto and myself we all just
got out we decided we were going to get
drunk
and we drank he says you can't be
driving my car like that because i had
taken off in the car
right i said dad i didn't when i knew we
were gonna do that i drove the car back
parked it and then i walked back and
he's oh okay
no problem good welcome home
and my mom says you said why don't you
tell them i used to leave and not come
home for the weekend
and i said mom and he goes aye so i said
mom
he's not mad at me it's okay yeah what
the so that's the first time i learned
that my dad used to stay off on fridays
maybe not come home
until sunday you know how [ __ ] hard
that is too yeah
well it's not the hardest to leave on
friday you know my grandfather would be
in the car drinking and he was like
everybody grabbed go get him and i would
say my grandma wants to tell her that i
[ __ ] it
i said all right and he sat out there
till like 11 from like 3 30 to 11.
and uh he ate and my grandma made chile
that was like 20 times hotter than any
other [ __ ] [ __ ] just
so that he would learn you know he'd
want to eat and you'd see on there
looking sweating you know 11 30 eating
and
you know like all right [ __ ] you
can sit out there for drinking for seven
hours but then you're gonna have to eat
this
night 20 times stronger than anything
i've ever made oh that's good stuff
that's good man it's good
so so leo um let's go through your tick
tock uh
linea jake because yeah you know if you
i mean imagine that
someone can could make a living girl off
of social media
that's what these about those are doing
yeah well i'm not smart enough to
comprehend
that's it so it was called musically
before exactly yeah i made it i i've
been on it for like a year and a half
now and when i made it i did one video i
was working at a tv station i used a
green screen there
and and this one video got me some
traction it got me like from 12
followers to like 4
000 overnight and so at that point i was
like okay like
you know i i always thought i was funny
i always thought i could do stuff like
that
and so then i kept going kept going kept
going and then i hit
10 000 30 000 90 thousand four hundred
thousand
and like last week i hit a million wow
and it's like and and so five months ago
i hit like seven hundred
thousand and five months ago i decided i
was living in reno
i decided to move over here because i
was like let me just you know what like
let me just go for it
if it doesn't work then i'll go i'll get
a job i'll go back to hanford i'll go to
reno wherever but like
i don't want to regret it and and you
know let me go try it and so that's when
i got here and i got here with two
thousand dollars
and nothing else i got an apartment with
with two of my friends
uh and and that's it and and i was like
all right like i have a month
to see how much money i can make on tick
tock and i'll just play it like that
i'll see how much money i can get paid
from the app and then if it doesn't work
i have a month to get a job you know so
i'm like all right good good
and then the first month i get a i get
my first major sponsorship like a beer
company
and so that one that was like all right
that pays too much how did that happen
who came to you with that because i
think
the i want to know the the ad agency hit
on my manager
and they and are you the manager
come on uh that so
so they hit up esteban at that time and
and they uh because his emails in my in
my
description on everything and so they
hit him up
and they do their little negotiation
stuff and then we booked it and i was
like all right two months of rent
and so that's how it's been i've been
there five months and now it's going
it's like i'm like right
another sponsorship another two three
months of rent you know and so i'm like
and so right now like last week i booked
my
latest one that i i'm gonna put together
this week and then it comes out like in
two weeks
and then the way that it works is i'll
get paid like a month or two after it
goes live on my tick tock
so then it's like all right like so now
at this point i've had like
seven sponsorships and and i'm getting
my first payment from my first one three
months ago
like this week and so i'm like all right
all right but i'm very like i got you
know i got that like
eviction trauma so i i have everything
like i
i just put it away right away and i'm
like all right like i don't see myself
as like i made this much
this pay period i made this much and
this is ran and it's going to go right
here in this envelope you know
until i can really feel like without
getting too personal i'm just curious
how do they pay they pay by the amount
of people that hit on your
view your your tick tock they are they
bad set fee this is it it's a flat rate
here why don't you go live on my account
and we can
go live right now yeah hi and show
yourself and show us but just talking
all right look at the ground you can
cover i'll do all three of us
all right baby you've never gone live um
you got a filter on i do yeah well first
i don't want people to think i got
really nice skin there it is well no no
we'll take it all the filters off yeah
i have that one that makes your bed
gonna look bigger
i need that one all right so
so yeah so let's talk to you it's just
been it's crazy
out of nowhere and and i was studying to
be a news reporter that's what happened
it's like
that's what i my first dream was like i
wanted to act
so i watched george a lot i was watching
like my favorite movie for a long time
my favorite movie for a long time was
swing vote remember
that was my favorite movie we did that
in mexico yep because it was like
it was it was a movie of uh of uh uh
it had news stuff which i was really
into and then it had george lopez in it
so it was like the best thing for me is
like journalism and george lopez
so that's what i was like i want i was
like i can't be an actor because i live
in hanford three and a half hours away
that's too far and logistically like
when i was little i
i never thought i would drive i never
thought i'd have a license i was just
very i was just scared of everything
you know and so i was like i'm never
gonna make it to la i'm never gonna
actually have the chance to be there and
so and so i just i was like you know
what i'll be a news reporter it's in
fresno
30 minutes away and then um and then
i was doing youtube videos i was doing
facebook videos and then nothing ever
worked
until tik tok a year and a half ago it's
crazy and so it's been a year and a half
and it changed my life
like completely because now i'm you know
not to
you know be all on some sappy [ __ ] but
like i'm sitting with
the guy who i just was the legend the
leader the master yeah and i know and i
know like i know he gets it i know
more ah no but i know like
you know people like do that all all the
time they say all these things and like
i
don't know what that's like but i'm like
bro like for me it's like it's
crazy what tick tock has done for my
life is crazy it's amazing
it's amazing yeah it is it's amazing
that all this could happen
and that be i think it keeps kids out of
could keep kids out of trouble
and i think it's perfect because like
during the pandemic
i feel like i can't imagine like what it
would have been like for me if i was a
kid in the pandemic
so i think about like they had this
opportunity to see
it it made people have the opportunity
to be stars
to to have their own following have have
their own everything
and so and for me like i'm just random
from hanford california some little cow
town right
and it gave me this opportunity and and
i don't enjoy yourself i'm showing you i
just showed you right now all right um
show guilt too and uh yeah so hey so
this is how crazy it is so
floyd mayweather 50 and 0 27 knockouts
fights are you a youtube what is that
guy your influencer oh
something like that yeah they fought
[ __ ] made i don't know how much money
100 million dollars or some [ __ ]
and uh those two guys would never fight
one six four
and one's five eight and he
lasted all eight rounds three minute
rounds it's incredible
amazing and everything you're you're
saying about
your shocked at the way everything's
turned around that's exactly because it
was
just in january that this documentary
came out
and my life flipped i i never would have
anticipated this in my life
especially this old did anybody ever see
that [ __ ] coming man
like the all the all the
advances in technology i did
i was still a solar power
i opened the [ __ ] shade so the tv
works but i mean
it's it's every it's everything and
everybody's phone you look at star trek
and they got to be talking into the
thing it's like we're way beyond that
[ __ ] yeah
people meet they meet they fall in love
they break up by text messages
some people don't even hardly even talk
anymore and in a way
it it's helping society and in a way
because kids do everything by the
computer i think that that
they don't write letters anymore they
don't they don't really know how to
write but then a guy you know kids can
make a living
doing you know tick tock my my my
daughter does it
doing tick tock
it yeah it's crazy just uh it just
and for me like i feel like it gave me a
family because even just last month they
flew me out to
i got flown to el paso just to get drunk
uh so i i i got some friends out of it
you know so i got friends there i got
people watching from all over the place
what do you mean who flew you some
random people that like they were just
like can you come kick it with us we'll
get your plane your
your home for that for that night i was
like bad like yeah
oh [ __ ] well tell them next time you've
got a best friend named gil carrillo
gallop right there yeah so i went yeah
so i feel like
so when i compare it to because two two
years ago
about two years ago before i moved away
to nevada for a year
i was sleeping in my car for the last
few weeks of my semester
wow and and i would and i was struggling
my mom was in the hospital i was
sleeping in the car
i couldn't i was working two jobs and
and just trying to take care of a few
things and
and then and that so now it's like even
like my friends today likes
that i've made now is crazy because like
i can't even begin to understand them
like
you don't like you don't understand how
much love i have for you
like i have so much love for you because
of like
comparing today to two years ago it just
doesn't make sense incredible
and so every all of this stuff is just
like it has been
just so so deep for me such a big deal
for me just to be
to be here like that doesn't make sense
uh you know and then they did uh
i used to work at univision in fresno i
worked as a photographer and editor for
almost three years and they just did a
story on me the other night they talked
about you a little bit
um [ __ ] you know he said they
did a story but they talked about you
talked about you i don't know i don't
know why
but that's but it's it it's impressive
man i mean you know
the only child scared of things i was an
only child scared of everything
and that's what i talked about when i
talked about here is that like i uh
watching the show
uh as a little boy i was like bro like
he makes it
funny to be an only child he makes it
funny to have
a messy mom you know and he makes it
funny to have your dad not there
like and so when i was watching it i was
like bro like and it was like
it was like according to jim reba george
lopez
seinfeld and so it was like that's me up
there like that's
that's me and and and not only is it
like he's brown too
but like his mom is like my mom like
they're both just
different people on in that show and his
dad is just
not there right so i was like damn like
that that's funny like that's
it's nice and i was i felt hopeful and
so that's what gave me my
like that's what you know you talked
about like personality earlier and i was
like
that's what gave me that part of my
personality was like i could
you know like that like that that's how
i kind of coped with that time of my
life
because i was we were my mom and i were
going from different home to different
home
some staying in someone's garage staying
and yeah
and during that time it was like i would
i couldn't really make a solid group of
friends because
we were just moving so much different
schools and and and you know
how you guys were moving just because
income or financial
financial stuff and and and you know my
mom you know she i think like she
struggled a lot she was a foster child
herself
and and she she never met her dad
and her mom passed away when like one
night when she was like 12 like
overnight
and so i always just like and so that's
why i gave a lot of
i just had a lot of grace growing up
because i was like you know what i'm
fine like i don't need that
i never asked her for anything i don't
know i never asked my dad for anything
because my dad was he was living in
mexico
and sometimes he'd be he he would live
in mexico he'd come to hand for work in
the fields
save some and then go live in mexico and
so
the fact that like him never saying i
love you i was like you know what like
i get wow like you don't have to say it
i i understand like you're struggling
right now and like so when he would be
drinking when i would see him and he'd
be like
drunk or whatever i'd be like i get it i
get it it's hard
it's hard for you [ __ ] i never got it
yeah
wow that's i just had that grace and so
now as an adult i've been trying to
keep that grace going um and i feel like
finally
with with the season that i'm in of my
life i feel like
that's what that grace was for like
that's why i needed to
just sit there and be quiet and just
pray and just like god like whatever
like whatever you're doing like i'll all
be here and like i'm just gonna not see
that
i'm just gonna pretend that i that i
that that that's not happening and i'm
just going to try to keep my eyes locked
how old are you i'm 26 now wow
yeah it's a lot to happen earlier you
know i think it's making it yeah
the way he is that's perfect i think
it's impressive are we ended or
do we end it uh i can end it no whatever
you want to do yeah
no no but but but it really is because
you know it's like um
i looked at tv but i didn't have an
interactive thing like
you can i mean i sent him a dm and i
said hey man let's try to let's try to
do something i don't even think he was
in la yet
but and he answered back so is it
easy to get a hold of somebody
absolutely you see your yes dms i don't
look at mine but but
um but somebody is just a short message
away man yeah
you know everybody everything seems so
attainable now because i
i mean think about you but i think about
this guy uh his name is nick coletti and
he would do a
vine back then and uh he's a comedian he
he's explained buying two vine was
the hottest i don't know before tick
tock so it was like little
little videos and people would do like
little skits and so
um and uh so but that app is gone now
but i think about
uh i was really into nick back then a
few years ago
do you know what that guy is grant uh no
no
yeah he he does stand up now as soon as
you said nick i was first thing i was
thinking of
ned coletti he's a doctor do we have any
more beer
one more one more guys is there any more
no so we get some more
yeah one yeah yeah i mean i'm good i'll
be
i'll be half i'm going to the dodger
game oh you are oh yeah
i'm going to the dodger game tonight um
yeah so i think about like nick coletti
i think like i was watching him a long
time ago and then he dm me one day and i
was like
well it was the same thing as like like
i was watching you
and and and the thing that i always
think about because
uh i'm just emotional is i'm like damn
like
i was watching you while i was going
through this particular season it's
crazy dude and so now i'm like damn like
it's just crazy to see like while that
stuff was going on
like this was already written is how i
feel like this this
this day was already written for me
that's exactly just at a different
different age
i would have never in my wildest
imagination thought that i'd be sitting
as a guest on the george lopez oh my god
a high podcast uh to be
have him have someone with his stature
call me up
and then get to meet him and know him
and sure we talked the first time on the
phone like for 25 minutes yeah and i
knew we were gonna we were already
friends but i was like oh i feel like
i've known this dude forever already
it's good
good we good i'm good no i mean you know
i mean whichever one this is uh
the you ever tried this one the hibiscus
that one's sour but i mean
you know all this is like brought us
together
yeah did you did you uh save it or put
it up there is it on there
yeah i'll save it um so
i mean [ __ ] it's crazy man and it is and
i'm sorry
so so what was your life
a little bit of what it was like before
january
like what was your day what were your
days like you know you're a great family
guy you travel
with your family i do stuff with my
family uh last year
the the year preceded it was not a good
year for me i had a lot of medical
issues going on with my lungs you know i
had
[ __ ] going on with my lungs i was in and
out of the hospital a couple of times
hopefully they took care of it and they
said well you got a leaky valve over
here
and i said i put some cheek let's do
something right and so we're still going
through that so i
are you still going you're still going
through that thing and so i was just
really
kind of like a homebody you know it
didn't go out that way you couldn't go
anywhere anyway
you know uh right so right my my
anniversary
uh which was a big one this year last
year was the day after christmas
it was my 50th wedding anniversary and
we said
amazing man you know my kids god bless
them they
they went ahead they decorated my house
like if it was uh
the movie it's a wonderful life yeah and
that's my wife's favorite movie of all
time you know
if you were a kid growing up around my
house don't let her get put her hands on
you when that movie time
comes on because you're going to sit
there and watch it she forced you to
watch it
and uh they decorated my house we were
gone for a couple hours they decorated
the house they had a
candlelight dinner for us when we came
home
we both just cried you know it was
beautiful and it's the best anniversary
we've ever had
which really in the long run because my
good friend
uh jimmy philippa had over at stevens we
had been planning this the year before
a big volatility yeah yeah yeah big
thing so
this saved me save me a bunch of money
uh but so we didn't do much last year it
was just a routine monday in life
i'm retired uh my wife has never worked
so
we stood home yeah they were doing as
you were doing right family comes over
you're done the pandemic trying to stay
safe and then exactly
this thing comes out in january and it's
my whole life has changed wow
whole life's changed for the good i i'm
not i'm not complaining at all
and i don't think that i've changed as a
person i i have to remain
humble you know i have to remain no
you're humble yeah never forget where
you came from
you know what's interesting about you
know i was now that we know each other
and you watch
you watch the night soccer series that
with no social media at that time and we
were talking about
how you would take somebody downtown to
go look at mug shots or
they had a uh artist i don't know where
they found the [ __ ] artist
that would draw people but yeah it kind
of didn't look like him and then it kind
of looks like him
right it kind of looks like somebody and
then it's not
you know it's not like they do now yeah
are you really looking at
is just lips and nose
and uh going downtown to look at
pictures
thousands of fingerprints like you said
what they call it the three s's with the
uh uh scotch snitch and shoe leather
just no
substitute for hard work nothing that
was it
although i never did become a scotch
drinker i was i was a tequila drinker
is that bar still open in chinatown that
you guys used to go to you mean
where they would slide the door and go
no that one's gone no that was
and that was gone uh but you may lose
the one on top
as far as i know still is i don't go
down to chinatown anymore too far nobody
goes down to chinatown
too far to drive i went to go get a
haircut one time in chinatown i cut all
my hair off
uh and uh the [ __ ] cut it so
short that the [ __ ] sun hit me i was
crying on my way to the car
parked across the street the sun is like
ah because you know i had hair and that
i didn't have hair
i should i don't know what he got to
but i was ready to be taken comfortable
i mean just on the way to the run into
the car like that
like just yeah oh he sees a barber pole
you know to go in
yeah it was it was good and every day it
gets different
like like the guy's drawing this picture
like you see a lot of artists you see
i'm sure people send stuff i got a guy
that draws pictures they send it to us
you see them all the time so you met
this artist where's this guy in
tennessee he's in tennessee
all through dm that's what started it
and now we're facing chicano guy or a
white no white guy
and uh just a different guy and i'm
grateful i had somebody contact me
uh said now that you're doing all this
stuff you know i see you're getting
bigger and bigger you need a uh
guard dog i raise and train guard dogs
and i said and he says
won't cost you anything i said thank you
but no thanks
my wife would never allow that you know
she'd be scared to death
and so although you train him to be good
i said
no thanks thank you very much and he was
raised right there and he said a matter
of fact
he used to go he says i live right there
by beverly and bradshaw
right on the montebello iselle border i
said they had a taco village right there
that's before king taco came out
[ __ ] and and taco village made the best
tacos
we'd go down there and grab that he says
i used to ride my bike there all the
time i said well there we go and now we
can meet there for lunch
you said how long you been in the house
that you've been in 47 years
[ __ ] 47 years wow you know and i'm so
proud
i'll tell you how much i owe on it now i
only owe
uh less than 60 000 and people say what
do you mean it's not paid for you've
been there all those years
i said wait a minute i'm the only one
that worked so there was
seconds oh wow you know a lot of stuff
you you wanted this you wanted that
i had to borrow money against my house
so now uh
and i'll have it paid off within three
years two three years and i'll have the
bait on what do you think
would you do something else if somebody
presented like you know how they do like
law and order like you know they do
based on
on something somebody presented you an
idea for a show
about you know your life as a detective
not a documentary but maybe you see like
blue bloods or something like that
would you would you be would you
consider that i think i'd be very
uh i'd be very interested in doing
something like that
uh because there's nothing in i mean
social there's nothing like
crime i mean you see people sure i mean
you know there's a lot of
clearly a lot of issues racially but but
crime is
is what it looks like it's fascinating
people uh right now
that's what it looks like and i'm hoping
that uh
somebody you know wants to do something
i'd be more than happy to listen to
anybody that wanted to do something like
that and hey
and i don't think you should be flying
to el paso to get drunk yeah
because you know what you i don't know
if you can really i mean you're a police
officer would you really trust somebody
that you've never met i
i wouldn't well i wouldn't you know
there'd have to be something more
substantial than just come on out and
you know
i because of the trust factor i i think
people have to be said you i think
people have to be safe right like guys
social media people and influencers and
people like that
that yeah i went because they they were
they were he's like does like
influencer stuff too he's like trying to
do that so i was like yeah
yeah but no i wouldn't i i did is there
a taco
is there an influencer comic con
not that i know of i or not that i've
gone to the level of
i i know that there's like call up call
the [ __ ] radisson
no no i know that there's like in
october i was part of a
an event that tick tock put on uh it was
like a latino
tick tocker tick tock creator of it and
that was like a virtual one
so i think this year is i'm hoping that
it'll be like a in-person thing sure
and and because uh yeah it would be like
like vidcon like one of those youtube
ones yeah
so so they so they do well they do adult
films they don't know if they do they
they could do that
we're gonna we're not we're gonna wrap
it up but then you you went to a crime
con right you went to the hospital
yes was that the weekend that that was
the shooting out there
just before i got out of town i got out
of dodge just in time i left there on
monday and i think the shooting was on
thursday
wow wednesday or thursday so explain to
everybody what this is the first time
you went to something like this i didn't
even know they had it
i didn't know that i didn't know they
had it they found me just a
a doctor of uh forensic psychology or
police psychologist
he uh i had met him he had seen me on
the dr
oz show and he had been on the doctor
awesome i haven't seen him on the doctor
yeah i did the dr oz show and and so
he went ahead and uh invited me out to
lunch by the house we went out to lunch
and we talked
and he had done some work with our
profiler from the department before
so i met him had lunch then he called me
up uh after we left he says hey you know
you got this crime con thing going over
there and i knew nothing about it he
said
would you mind if i just submitted your
name he said i think they'd love you
and i said go ahead submit my name next
thing i know they're inviting me out
there they
they're all excited uh no this one was
for free all i told them was okay
if i'm gonna go you gotta fly me out
first class i'm not gonna go back in the
coach because
me and coach is like a ten pound chorizo
and a five pound skin
you know so it doesn't work so you fly
me out there you can pay for everything
once i get there and that's it i'll do
it for you guys
so we did it it worked out i'm so glad i
went they were so good
so professional right the way they did
everything the way it went on
uh it was just first first-class
operations
and and people that were there were
paying money to who else was there like
who were the other guys uh dr phil was
there
uh what are they helen grace i think the
the attorney the the
oh nancy grace nancy gracie she was on
there
uh helen grace is the chocolates helen
grace
you get there you have a big big big
night is that covering this
white in the background all right and
then
they had the guy that plays homicide
hunter uh
he's an actor he was there who's a
homicide hunter that that dude joe
joe somebody uh joe panda
well this is a guy that plays portrays
joe kinder
carl carl moreno nice guy
both him and his wife i sat and had
dinner with him one night nice
nice nice people uh there was one that i
missed okay they're having a speaker
there
uh there was a daughter of the btk
killer
and she was going to speak at 10 o'clock
sunday morning and i wanted
i wanted to see her because i had been
called while i was still working cop out
here
they had called and asked me if i'd go
consult with them
because of my expertise they wanted me
to go consume what year was that
uh that was you know who the btk killer
is no
bind them torture kill them and dude
that was in the 90s
early 2000s whenever they arrested them
because one of the most notorious serial
killers of
all time in wichita kansas in wichita
kansas
they they asked me if i'd go consult
with them i said yes well three weeks
before i'm due
out there [ __ ] they they made the arrest
so i called him out i said hey well i
guess all bets are off you don't need me
anymore
congratulations good luck and they said
oh no no no that was the arrest is made
but we still have a trial to go through
we want to talk to you about what to
prepare for what can we expect ahead
and not only that we've scheduled a
seminar which we're hoping
you're willing to put on a class for us
so i went back there anyway so now i
wanted to see what the daughter had to
say i never spoken with her
and i it was very interesting to me
unfortunately
i'm there on saturday and i had to go to
their dinner i kind of snuck out of
their dinner because it was boring
and i went over to the bar to get a
glass of wine
and i went to go get and they said i was
by myself so they're going to sit me in
the corner in the back over here on the
side
and then as i'm walking through three
ladies who had
paid the big bucks to be a vip saw him
and he said hey where you guys well i'm
going to go over here and have a glass
of wine
what were you with by myself why don't
you join us
so i sat down with those ladies and
at one o'clock in the morning when the
bar closed they said okay that's it
you know and you miss it in the morning
yeah i got up the next morning i said no
no
discretion being the better part of
valor i'm staying in the room i ain't
going out right now
i wasn't hungover i was just tired yeah
and i knew i had to speak
that afternoon so i didn't want to go
out but that the daughter would be
buried that's a big that's a big kind of
get
so the btk guy was he wanted to be a
police officer
he was a deacon for his church he was a
boy scout master he was an animal
control employee
uh the nice neighbor nobody ever would
he was by the book like if he went
and he he would be the guy that says you
know
this is not to regulation and you're
like does that [ __ ] guy have anything
better to do
like he he was one of those guys that
would
use his authority you know it's like a
security guard that really wanted to be
a police officer and he's not but
he [ __ ] [ __ ] with everybody and he
became that guy
he was just a harvey milk close guy when
he's not doing working and then all of a
sudden to find out
he is who he is was a shock to everybody
including his family
so i wanted to listen to his daughter
but i missed her
that's the only one that i really missed
but the and he went dormant for
about 30 years almost 30 years he went
he was which which would have meant that
he would have uh essentially gotten away
with
exactly with it all only because he
started messing with the computer he'll
send messages
i'm going to start again you know and
that's what got him caught
and like ego
and which you probably see a lot of uh
in in social media everybody everybody
has to think they're more important than
somebody else
right because that's kind of social
media
it feeds insecurity this dude went away
for that long
and didn't like that they didn't
what put them on the list with like some
of the most notorious he wanted he
wanted attention he still wanted
attention he was out
completely safe out never they never
probably would have not got him
then he came back in a time where
there's now let's not say they wouldn't
have got him they called me the
consultant oh yeah
but what were the clues though there was
no you know i was the only guy from
outside their department they got to go
they took me into what we call the war
room
they had evidence up in the walls and
maps and all this stuff it was
fascinating
fascinating stuff they had just like a
room with all the
clues and pictures and things yeah yeah
that'd be you up there on the wall cover
when you go to the classroom go get
drunk
be careful huh they'll see you throw
them high heels out with lipstick
kissed off can i see him yeah all right
so yeah
so thank you guys hey grant how do we do
man all right
great you want us to go to see the
dodgers no i don't care about seeing the
dodgers i tell you
after we get off the air i'll tell you
where i got to go okay
yeah i do all right you're always
welcome back
all right nice to see you here brother
good to see you i think it's fun huh it
was a pleasure meeting you let's do that
come back come back over here for this
hang out like the three of us i'm down
we'll bring it be real with the picture
right there all right thank you guys see
you next time
you